قبل ثمانيه اشهر عد اعلان الرئيس الامريكي
عن اصابته بمرض السرطان زله لسانا لكثره
زلته لكن البيت الابيض اعلن بالفعل ازاله
ورم جلدي سرطاني من صدر الرئيس الشهر
الماضي جميع الانسجه السرطانيه تمت
ازالتها بنجاح خلال العمليه الروتينيه
للرئيس في السادس عشر من فبراير ولا يحتاج
الرئيس الى مزيد من العلاج
طبيب بايدن اكد الشفاء موقع الخزعه بشكل
تام موضحا انها السرطان الخلايا القاعديه
وبحسب مواقع طبيه انه شكل شائع من اورام
الجلد الخبيثه نادرا ما ينتشر الى باقي
الجسم او يؤدي الى الموت لكنه يكبر حجما
ويغزو الانسجه المحيطه به مسببا دمرها
وتشويها ورغم تبيان فحص بايدن البدني
السنوي في فبراير انه لائق للعمل يتواصل
الجدل بين الامريكيين حول قدره رئيسهم
الحالي على اجتياز اربع سنوات اخرى في
المكتب البيضاوي مع تشكيكهم بانجازاته
خلال اول سنتين من عهده علما بان الرئيس
الامريكي لا يزال عندانيه الترشح مجددا
ولم يعلن ذلك رسميا بعد برامج
دينا لدعم حمله اعاده انتخاب بايدن تراجعت
بشكل كبير لاسيما بين الاصغر سنانا ووصلت
لسبعه وثلاثين في المئه وفق استطلاع للراي
اجريا الشهر الماضي فالكثيرون قلقون من ان
سنوات الرئيس الثمانين ستمثل عبئا كبيرا
مع وضعه الصحي وتلعثمه الدائم وتؤثر سلبا
في ممارسه مهامه